is that all right there yeah okay thank
you
Okay so
uh good afternoon
let me start that again good afternoon
everybody
um welcome to East Aurora our home base
of operations for pelagic Research
Services I'm Jeff Mahoney director of
information and media relations uh thank
you for allowing us this opportunity to
provide you with some of the details
about our part in the collective
response of the
Titan submersible
tight and submersible
um tragedy really and the subsequent
recovery
I want to introduce Edward Cassano the
CEO of pelagic Research Services who
with Jim Sloan co-founded PRS in Santa
Barbara California
Ed was the coordinator of our subsea
assets aboard the Horizon Arctic with
Captain Adam Myers and his crew brought
the integrated team into the rescue
window
under the direction of the on-site
Incident Commander aboard the Canadian
Coast Guard ship Cabot and in
coordination with the captain and
response team aboard the Deep ship the
Sheep the ship deep energy
Ed oversaw the pelagic team's response
from mobilization through all offshore
objectives today we will be able to
speak to the response that got us to the
site of the missing submersible Titan
the coordinated plan as rescue on site
and the operational capabilities of the
ROV Odysseus
we will be able to talk a little bit
about what happened offshore and our
role in the overall operation
however we cannot talk about the
specifics of our role during recovery or
the specifics of any items recovered
beyond what currently exists in the
public record due to the sensitivity of
the ongoing investigation questions of
that nature need to be directed to the
U.S Coast Guard which is overseeing this
investigation
and with that I'm going to turn over to
Edward Cassano
as we start today and we start this
conversation that we're going to have I
want to ask us to keep grounded in the
solemnity of this event
throughout the entire evolution of this
response
this same fundamental Focus
was at the core of how all of our teams
did their jobs
during the urgency of the rescue at hand
we were always conscious of the crew of
the Titan
their families and friends
and the safety of all the responders
we focused our efforts
to arrive on the site of Titanic
prepared to rescue Titan
I have to acknowledge our team here many
of them are heading home
many of them are still traveling
and we have team members here I just
want to point out Jesse Doran who's our
ROV manager director of operations and
other members of the team here
the first thing I'm going to do is give
you a timeline of events
give you a sense of the sequence
so it started June 18th
Sunday
the loss of the communications and
tracking to Titan about 1745 local
meantime eastern daylight time we were
contacted by Ocean Gate
I landed at JFK airport at around 11
o'clock and was in conversation with
their director of operations immediately
assessed the situation
and we were asked to activate our deep
water remotely operated vehicle system
Odysseus 6K
we immediately began assembling
a team sending some to St John's
immediately and sending others here to
East Aurora
on June 19th which is Monday PRS began
packing and mobilizing the Odysseus 6K
ROV
throughout the day PRS staff arrived
on-site and by late afternoon
PRS was at Buffalo Niagara International
Airport mobilized for deployment where
two U.S Air Force c-17s were waiting for
us
with the equipment stage at the airport
PRS awaited arrival of yet another C-17
with additional equipment required to
not only load our kit at Buffalo but to
offload it at St John's Newfoundland
International Airport
Tuesday June 20th 0-400 we began loading
to the three c-17s
at the airport
we soon Departed
arriving at St John's Newfoundland
in the early afternoon
all three aircrafts sequenced
all three aircraft organized in a manner
to acquire the most efficient
mobilization
to the ship Horizon Arctic
which is waiting for us
the offload was immediate
and focused
awaiting us was a ship and a team and a
community ready to engage us
to get us onto the ship and to get us
underway
the last load container ship
you know the truck arrived at the peer
side
on June 20th the ship was underway the
next day June 21st at 05 30.
from the last truck arriving
to us leaving the pier
was about five and a half to six hours
seventy thousand pounds of equipment
ship
underway sight of Titanic and the loss
of
for the missing submersible at this
point of course was Titan I just want to
emphasize the whole response team that
we were going to integrate into was
underway there were at least 10 ships an
aircraft active already on site
Odysseus 6K as the 6000 meter mobile ROV
system became the primary asset focused
on Rescue
underway to the site we've finished the
integration and activation of the
vehicle and rigged it for Rescue plain
and simple we're focused on Rescue
we arrived on site
less than 24 hours later 0430 local
meantime The Horizon Arctic
integrated into the ongoing and
Multinational
rescue effort
at that point within an hour 0530
our system was launched from the back
deck
and began to descend to the seafloor
shortly after arriving on the sea floor
we discovered the debris
of the Titan submersible
of course we continue to document the
site
and by 12 o'clock
sadly a rescue turned into a recovery
I have to apologize we're we're still
demobilizing
it's a lot of emotions people are tired
during this period upon arriving on site
we'd have to point out that the U.S
Coast Guard incident command
reached out to the families of the Titan
crew Upon Our discovery of the debris
very important communication
we can then continue then of course to
perform an operation from Rescue to
recovery
so from basically June 22nd
until June 27th at 9 30.
our teams and I say our teams because it
was the integrated team of the Horizon
Arctic
and the pelagic team and many many many
others
who are conducting 24-hour ROV
operations
as directed by the on-site Commander
we of course use our heavy lift
capability
to recover all the objects of Interest
as directed by the incident response
team
just to complete the timeline for you
on June 28th
0730 local meantime St John's
Newfoundland
Horizon Arctic with the pelagic Embark
team
arrived at the Canadian Coast Guard base
where wreckage was offloaded and our
demobilization began
today is June 30th
and it's 24 hours ago we were on site
we really have to take that into
perspective
before taking questions a few more
points
we're still reviewing the sequence of
events that we were a part of
during the drive from New York JFK to
here
the incident command structure of course
had been activated for a few days and
that integrated command structure that
we were participating in was being
facilitated by vice admiral William J
glanis Who's the commander of Naval C
systems command
so after Ocean Gate had activated us we
were immediately blended into the
incident command structure
I asked us all here today to recognize a
seriousness of
the seriousness of the event
and respect the depth and range of
emotions certainly and most importantly
the family and friends of the Titan
and all those
in the response
I'm happy to take questions
kind of
the protocol that you found sure there
was a clearly when we arrived on site
you know we became that we were the
primary identified asset to affect
Rescue
there was a fleet of ships there we came
in next to a ship called Deep energy an
industry ship
their vehicle was at 2 700 meters they
were not capable of going deeper but I
want to point out that deep energy had
sent they had two rovs prior to our
arrival on site they had sent one ROV to
seafloor beyond their death capability
and it unfortunately mechanically had an
issue so that is just the scope of the
efforts they lost a vehicle
trying to get to seafloor so when we
arrived on site
we were slotted as primary
we came right next to deep energy this
is this we're in a 400 foot ship deep
Energy's six seven hundred foot ship we
were 75 meters apart
okay they had a lifting line at 3 000
meters
waiting to recover our focus our plan
was to integrate
the lifting mechanism into the center
core and the lifting capabilities of
Odysseus 6K so our plan of rescue was to
immediately upon finding Titan
latch onto her as quickly as possible
and begin recovery
there were protocols in the event of the
scenario of viability and non-viability
so it was wild
there were ships we were moving assets
under the integration and coordination
with incident command and the team on
deep energy but because we were primary
they were asking us to make the
decisions about how the various assets
would move
so when we did discover
the wreck of the Titan with different
sets of protocols went through
were you aware of what ocean gate was
doing prior to this whole event taking
place it's a very small community so the
answer is yes
I mean I really don't have it I mean
they I don't have a necessarily an
opinion on that where it's a strong
investigation going on right now uh
explorers people who seek to be on the
ocean to go to depth
it's very compelling we certainly
share those desires our whole company is
designed to support research and science
at depth so
it was a passion and a
and a you know a joy for exploration so
sure yeah so the the Odysseus 6K is a
remotely operated vehicle meaning it
operates from a ship through a tether
this is the control room of the system
this is actually the full kit as it is
mobilized onto a ship so it's a compact
mobile six thousand meter deep water
system and that's one of its design key
design characteristics we've always
known and we've always wanted to be
available for these types of situations
wish the call never came what we wanted
to be ready when it did
and so it's designed to withstand depths
up to 6 000 meters all the equipment
everything on there has to operate at
that depth importantly it has seven
function manipulators high definition 4K
cameras heavy lift capability of
multiple multiplicity of tools to allow
us to do work at depth
where was Odysseus built
so Odysseus 6K is a our design and it
was built by mph Engineering in Largo
Florida a very strong collaboration with
the fabricator and we worked together to
build this system it first became
operational in 2016. in our primary
Market is deep sea science
so we've worked a lot with the
University of Victoria ocean networks
Canada's example NOAA and other groups
this is our operational base we're a
mobile system
so in a sense we can be anywhere
so this entire vehicle
goes to the sea floor what you're seeing
here is an integrated launch and
recovery system you can barely see the
umbilical here this allows the vehicle
to be taken off deck rotated over the
side and then lower to the sea floor
in this image here
you can see the whole setup right so
here's our integrated launch and
recovery system our which with 7 000
meters of umbilical
control room which is there Workshop
we're independent of a ship and that's
part of our plan right we're waiting to
come in and function immediately and I
say that but I also need to point out
that
the success or the opportunity for
Success the opportunity to be on site
and Achieve what we all hoped we would
achieve
is a function of integrating with a ship
we have a philosophy called one team
it has to work the ship crew the
embarked science or in this case the
other personnel and our ROV team have to
become one team
it's a very dangerous thing that happens
out there out there
offloading it from a truck
just offloading it from a truck is
dangerous we have to keep you know our
thing is Safety First
safety of personnel number one
safety of equipment number two
and objectives number three now I will
say we pushed some things and everybody
pushed some things on this response
now you're they you you said you're
that's a unique design for you guys
right this is your design are you the
only ones with the equipment capable to
go down that low and recover what you
did based on the fact that the other
ship they're uh unit malfunction they
didn't malfunction what they pushed it
Beyond its depth rating so did your say
does yours is your machine one of the
few that can actually go down that far
and be okay yes I mean there are other
systems like it certainly they exist in
many parts of the world
but I think what makes our system
somewhat unique is its capabilities and
its Mobility
I want to speak to the facts about
operations it really is a testament to
the design and the functionality because
we're looking at
a almost Flawless operation 24 7. I
think that's a very good point I mean
in some ways I think you know as we look
back at this which we will
it was unprecedented in this sense our
ability to arrive at seafloor and then
go to work
and then we worked for another five or
six days at 3 800 meters and then we
began the recovery operations which in
and of themselves are quite challenging
can you discuss a little bit
a little bit mention your rescue you
were rape
articulating arms have been able to say
attach a cable to tighten if it had not
included to try to lift it off the
surface or the sea floor is that kind of
what you were getting there yeah we felt
we would be faced with
four potential scenarios
of course the scenario we wanted was
Titan just lightly on the sea floor
the crew
intact the pressure vessel intact that
would have made the sub slightly
negative or maybe slightly buoyant the
what we did is we tied a you know a
lifting mechanism into the center core
of the vehicle which we could not detach
right the the sub was not being tracked
they lost tracking and communication
which means we didn't know where it was
and subsea navigation
and knowing where you are is essential
for safe operations
we were tracking our vehicle so once we
were the plan was to grab the Titan
and once grabbed the Titan with our
manipulators then we had her
then it was going to be attaching
beacons we were carrying extra beacons
so if we lost her other assets could
track her and then we were going to
attach this heavy lift capability
to
the sub
at that point we would begin recovery
so the additional planning included
the other rovs that were right with us
they were holding a 2700 meters The
Horizon Arctic itself had another ROV we
were prepared that vehicle was prepared
to launch we were prepared to launch
that second vehicle
to once we came through 3 000 meters
then these other vehicles could join us
and they would also grab on we didn't
want to lose her and then at that point
we'd begin the translation to the heavy
lift line that deep energy had and I
can't say enough about the the
professionalism and the preparation of
the entire response
that allowed us to come in as primary
and have that waiting for us I mean it's
just it's a little hard to explain and
the visual of course is in all of our
head but that was a real opportunity
the time ticked away obviously there's a
lot of talk of course about the oxygen
running out can you kind of describe the
mood in the room for you and the crew
and really the pressure that you were
feeling as time kind of ticked away
I I can answer that actually pretty
simply we were focused at the job at
hand
that's what we do that's what all of
these people do we were laser focused on
rescue
of course we had to describe several
scenarios but we were not set for
anything else but recovering that
submersible
and that's what everybody was focused on
so it was laser focus job at hand safety
get it done
and so the debris that did come up that
was your machine the Odysseus that
brought that up yes
how many crew members
it's really hard to I mean our team was
nine but we immediately integrated into
a larger structure on Horizon Arctic for
example their own ROV had six crew they
became part of our team this concept of
one team
the entire crew of the Arctic the
captain Adam Myers and I worked
you know seamlessly together we had our
supervisors
um our dive supervisors so you know I
was saying Jesse was running the entire
deck Ops for us you know the whole ROV
operation but our team
we assembled an expert team that has
worked with us for the years and that
was part of the opportunity for Success
right is that you have to have we talk a
lot about equipment but it's really
ultimately about people and we are
really fortunate to have great people
and we were really fortunate to move
into a environment where they were
equally a high level of professionals
as a rescuer and recovering Ben partier
plan right from the beginning or is
there something new that you confronted
we always knew that we'd be called at
some point and so we prepared the system
for that we could have been out on a job
and we wouldn't have been
out there
there were other assets that mobilized
as well there was a French ship with
their vehicle they were very importantly
theirs back you know they were if it was
not a race but it's just everybody was
going there and we had been designated
primary because the thought was we would
be arriving on site first which we did
how much did this did this cost
advancement
[Music]
what have you guys learned
that will that will advance the the
undersea exploration
I think there's a lot to learn I think
we're very proud of the performance of
our system it performed our team
performed so it it actually
achieved the mission at hand we're very
saddened we couldn't recover a viable
sub
but beyond that the system performed
down the road there are certainly things
that we'll think about but we haven't
had time to assess that
knowing that but also there's I got to
tell you there's a strong sense of pride
in this community that you're here
because some people have said you know
why weren't they over at the coast I
know you're in South Wellesley
Massachusetts you mentioned Santa
Barbara what was it about East Aurora
they decided to establish or base here
and we don't want you to put you but is
there any discussion perhaps to have you
on a coastal or a coastal environment
we're a mobile system
we just got to St John's Newfoundland
and probably less than 30 hours so we're
designed for Mobility so in a sense we
can be anywhere but I've talked about
people and community and I I really want
to say this that and I'm going to
describe this community
this is one community of probably dozens
of communities around the world that
came together and that's why we were
successful in getting this system
mobilized to the airport to St John's
onto the ship onto site onto the C4
community and so we're we are also happy
to be here and we have no intent of
leaving exactly
what brings this this
that guy over there
Jessie doing
and if I had
I always just say a thousand dollars for
every time somebody asked me that
question
I might be retired but uh I say this
right we have so Eric Peterson is here
Eric Eric is mph engineering he designed
and built this vehicle with us and he's
another example of
the expertise that needs to come
together to create something like this
but not only is the design solid but the
operational capability when I called and
Eric is one of you know half a dozen to
a dozen individuals we called who just
dropped everything they came from
Skagway from Vancouver British Columbia
from Austin Texas from uh Louisiana
you know from uh Newfoundland from Nova
Scotia to assemble and to make this a
reality of chance that would be the
Odysseus six catering just to clarify it
wasn't based here but I mean what what
is
done here it is based here it is based
here okay it's normally you wouldn't be
able to stand where you're standing okay
okay but we like it when it's not here
because it means it's working
but we also like it when it is here
it's arriving on Monday so currently uh
you know it's on trucks three trucks and
it's heading back here
and he has said that in light of this
tragedy he would hope that other
exploration firms like
we consider having your equipment either
on site or standing by not forbid it was
needed
do you think that would also be a future
mission for you to work more so with
these companies that you said they got
them out they called you immediately and
said
well would you expect in the future
you'll be doing more of that just in
case God forbid we had another
situations
I think certainly you know we want to
make ourselves available as the
environment requires so I mean we would
certainly consider
you know we we work in the Science World
we support the exploration community
you know and so of course
efficiency of deployment
if you have integrating with other group
teams how does that happen
deal with professionals
you have to have good leadership
you have to have trust and faith that
the folks that are experts
will execute on their job and that
happens over time
that happens with experience
and it worked
you know I can't imagine you would be
able to train for this kind of stuff too
often it's so expensive but I mean how
how do you get that level of
efficiencies can't just be a bunch of
professionals they might have different
ideas and have things
the folks that are great at this come
from a variety of communities
they can be auto mechanics that have a
passion for the ocean and have a skill
with their hands they can be trained
formally as Pilots they can have a
passion for engineering It's a
combination of skills and personality
that make for Success you have to have
experience I mean there's no question
that you have to gain experience because
it's a very complex operation you know
fraught with danger but High reward
and you should also point out that there
is a very experience and structured
chain of command it's not a group of
people just race racing together and and
calling their own shots yeah I mean we
you know a ship environment at sea
you know operations are they're strive
they're structure there's hierarchy uh
there's a level of communication and uh
action and it's because of and that's
true and whenever you're operating in a
in a dangerous environment it's
especially true when you're at Sea I
mean the captain
is in fact
ultimately in command and so working
very closely with Adam Myers you know we
had to form an immediate
Bond and level of trust with each other
and that was incredible so okay
you guys being based so close to the
Great Lakes is is that kind of a nice I
know they're not as deep as maybe the
ocean but are those nice little testing
grounds where you go out and kind of
test some equipment and other things
we'd love to we'd love to go into the
Great Lakes um we haven't been there yet
um there's some great things to look at
we have a test tank that's outside there
so we actually test our vehicle just in
that tank out there and that allows us
to run it and be prepared in a sense
that's what we did we were the vehicle
was in a ready State
um so
we needed an invite moving 70 000 pounds
of equipment is not inexpensive I know
you're the captain
but and they're probably gonna
I think I think that as you sir I don't
know is there anything you'd be willing
to say just watching this machine
actually doing what it did not to Globe
but to know that what can build really
was an integral part of this process is
there anything you care to say
describe that uh would you be able to
say out there sir
um
I just wanna I will say uh Eric please
do that but just I'd like to keep it
with here because these guys have been
through a lot of them
just what was going
when you saw
Odyssey is working I mean this was the
machine that you kind of brought the
light if you know what was going through
your mind seeing how it's performing
I don't know I think at that moment it
wasn't so much about you know something
that I had done it was kind of just the
whole
there's a much bigger picture at that
moment that didn't that wasn't wasn't
you know it was a much bigger picture it
wasn't me or or that it was the entire
the entirety of what was happening right
but I guess what I'm just getting at but
it was working the way you hoped that
you knew it would but you also hoped it
would yeah that depth just to see if
they're working
um I mean every time it goes in there's
you know like confidence that of course
it's going to work but still in the back
of your head you know it's like if it
ever wasn't going to please don't it be
right now you know but it worked great
so yeah I think the thing to say is that
there's a collective team that's
involved in
going to operations
and so the spares and the expertise of
the team allow us to enter into an
environment with confidence look things
break and it's not a design issue it's
just you're putting
Hydraulics fiber optics electrical
and you're throwing it over the side in
a saltwater environment and driving it
down four thousand meters so things do
go wrong
you have to fix it and that requires the
proper equipment the proper sparing and
the proper team
sir what was your first last name um
Eric Peterson
Eric real quick can you can you discuss
your ties to the community did you grow
up here did you I'm from Clearwater
Florida okay yeah so I I got called
Sunday night and then I was on a plane
Monday morning what's your last names uh
Peterson p-e-t-e-r-s-o-n okay and again
the company you're with um mph
engineering mph
um Largo
thank you how long did it take to get
from surface to see before yeah all
right thanks took us about an hour and a
half
and that's normally it's faster than we
normally do we talk about some of the
changes that we made and one of them was
our December
so we normally descended 25 meters a
minute the team had us descending at 35
meters a month how did the how did the
company end up
so Jesse Doran lives in East Aurora and
we you know we talk about people and the
importance of people uh the importance
of keeping the equipment uh in a ready
state so it made total sense for us to
be here and for it to be maintained and
then operated from here so this is our
operational base we you know
and if I can
as much that's right just to follow up
on the engineering and the the
capability of the machine I'm sure by
following the story you all read about
the extreme environment I mean this is
the currents and the the pressures
very prevalent and the fact that the
Odysseus was able to operate 24 7.
almost flawlessly
if you're in the deep ocean community
that's remarkable so I again you know
what Eric has been able to achieve
really needs to be underscored because
this is this is unprecedented
an hour and a half hour and a half
very soon after
no this is from another project but this
is where we would that's where the
vehicle is operated from
shorts Cassano CA s-s-a-n-o
thank you thank you thank you very much